hello everyone and welcome to round six
of this year's Super bet chess classic
we've had a lot of very interesting
classical games so far but this one is
uh well it's really weird to put it
mildly now you'll see what I mean by
this and if you're wondering about the
title of the video it's something Yasser
saravan said during the uh the game
sometimes in the middle of the game uh
he had a reminiscent sort of of the game
that uh Wesley so played with the white
piece against Gary Kasparov in 2016 I
think it was the uh some sort of a St
Louis Blitz tournament uh where uh
Kasparov got absolutely crushed by
Wesley and then he said that after the
game that he felt as if their game was
uh morphe versus amateur because Wesley
crushed him so hard uh it's sort of like
a Morpheus to crush amateur players back
you know in the day like 150 years ago
so you'll see what I mean by this let's
check it out a world champion dingler
and has the white pieces and he opens
with Pawn to C4 he goes for his English
opening Knight to F6 by Wesley we have
Knight to C3 with Ponte 5 and now
usually you'll see Knight to F3 or G3
here those are the top moves here but
dingo's for E3 it's sort of a slow slow
line uh Bishop to B4 and now Knight to G
to E2 we have castles and Ponte A3 now
it is uh uh fairly uh rare system but it
has been used by none other than former
world champion Magnus Carlsen quite a
few times and he won some very nice
games with it so Bishop back to A7 and
now Pawn to D4 we have e captures Queen
captures and now uh in the games that
I've discussed for example Magnus
Carlson a defeated Levon aronian in the
St Louis Blitz tournament in 2020 but
that game continued with Knight to c6s
have most others that reach this
position but here Wesley plays this
weird Knight the A6 move and there's
only one game in the database that reach
this position and it's between a couple
of a lower rated uh players so the idea
is okay now you control C5 you can play
Bishop to C5 you can play Knight to C5
you can play Pawn to see if I bring the
Knight to C7 then the E6 so you have to
be a bit careful here ending just brings
the queen back Queen to D1 and now in
the game that we mentioned Knight the C5
was played but here we have gone to C6
and it is already now as of movie that
we have a completely new game and it's
uh well if you if you want a good chance
against the world champion with the with
the black pieces then this is definitely
what you go for uh Knight to F4 biting
and now Knight to C7 we have fun to E4
grabbing more space controlling that D5
square and just Rook to E8 preparing to
put pressure on that E4 Pawn we have
Bishop to E2 and now just the bishop to
f8 so for the moment preventing from
castling as the E4 Pawn is hanging so
Queen to D3 a very natural move you want
to develop your queen defend the pawn
here now Queen to E7 just continuing to
put pressure on that E4 Pawn so F3 does
also seems like a move you want to play
the E4 Pawn is now nicely protected you
also control the Knight on F6 very
nicely uh Queen to E5 nicely
centralizing the queen and now while you
could Castle uh ding first goes for
Knight to H3 he wants to re-maneuver his
Knight to F2 and this is used by uh
Wesley to go Pawn D5 saying Knight H3 is
too slow and I'm gonna take advantage of
this and okay uh done H3 also guards the
F4 Square so Bishop to F4 it's also a
nice way to get a few Tempe in Queen
back to E7 and the one of the problems
for ding is that he this is only move 15
he's already down to 28 minutes and the
clock whereas Wesley has almost an hour
on the clock and now you have to react
the the this D5 Pawn the problem is if
you're going let's say Knight to F2
which you kind of planned for Knight the
E6 is coming which comes with an attack
on the bishop then you move the bishop
then D4 comes attacks the Knight already
Wesley would have a defended pass Pawn
on D4 so and maybe giving them a bit
much so first C captures on D5 and now
you don't have Bishop captures on H3
it'd be great if you did but if Bishop
captures an H3 now then D6 could be an
issue like it's not lost for black or
anything it's like super complicated
Queen to D7 and now after G captures on
H3 you can play Knight the H5 go for the
bishop and now okay if you move the
bishop then you lose control of this
Pawn if you move the bishop here then
black just trades captures captures and
then you lose the pawn let's say queen
side castles and rookate to d8 and this
is a position that um
uh well then we would definitely enjoy
seeing in top level chess but of course
the being avoids that sea captain 75 was
played C captures on D5 and now Knight
to F2 so keeping an eye on everything
Knights the E6 attacking the bishop and
the bishop to E3 and here comes the move
that Wesley took a few minutes to
calculate because if it works then you
know that you're in for uh uh for for uh
a very interesting game Pawn to D4 here
a Wesley sacrifices a pawn and you
absolutely have to accept this Pawn uh
because both of your pieces are attacked
here so Bishop camp for Sunday for now
Rook to d8 goes after the bishop and you
can defend it if Knight B5 just spawn to
A6 you have to play uh Bishop captures
and F6 attack the queen on E7 Queen
captures an F6 leaving the queen and D3
still attacked and now comes Knight to
G4 if you're wondering why not just play
Knight to D5 attack the black queen well
the problem is then Queen captures on B2
and it's just um very tricky for example
if you Castle now then comes Knight to
F4 attacks the queen attacks the bishop
the bishop is already hanging white just
resigns this so you can't really Castle
here you would have to play something
like Queen to B1 but then you can just
trade captures captures Bishop captures
and A3 and from that position where
you've sacrificed upon now you're up
upon and you also have two connected
pass pawns ready to be pushed forward so
that's the problem so after this queen
captures an F6
um uh ding said all right I can't really
go for that he plays Knights the G for
now attacks the black queen queen to G5
and now uh Pawn to H4
uh you could also play Queen day three
here uh but then you run into Knight F4
now threatening Knight captures and G2
with a with a beautiful Fork then comes
spawn to H4 attacking the black queen
and after we play Knight captures on G2
King F2 Knight captures an E3 H captors
and G5 you're gonna uh play Knight
captures on G4 and you're gonna have a
position like this Rook to D2 a
beautiful active Rook the bishop pair uh
you have two Pawn Islands um uh Dean
would have three Pawn Islands also a
messed up Pawn structure on the king
side so this would again be much much
better for black but H4 uh is uh is an
attempt to sort of avoid all this but it
doesn't help uh Queen to A5 uh now how
can how can you continue here Queen to
B5 of course Dean wants to trade queens
now Queen to C7 ding says your dark
squares are absolutely horrible here I'm
gonna play Queen to G3 here and there's
no way for you to uh the the survive
this and also if you just Castle here
then the problem again is Queen to G 3
and then the Knight is coming to 4 and
you haven't really castled the safety
which castling is kind of what you what
you use it for so here Knight to D5
again attacking the queen here Queen to
G3 check and King to F1 and here this is
the moment that everyone uh was waiting
for and this is what the author meant
when he said that uh Kasparov said that
about his game against Wesley there was
morphe versus amateur feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best move for Wesley uh while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
absolutely wild variation and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is The Rook captures on D5 uh Wesley
did not play it just just a heads up but
just to show you what's going on he
captures on the five Knight to F4 and
how are you defending this position it's
uh quite uh quite a beauty let's say
Knight D3 uh you uh add a Defender to
the G2 Pawn now A6 you kick away the
queen from this diagonal Queen A5 let's
say Bishop D7 uh and uh well whatever
white plays is just insufficient it's
very hard to to get a move in you can't
move any of your pieces let's say Queen
Seven attacks the bishop now even a move
like a rook to E8 going after the Knight
and now after a trade here let's say
queen captures you're gonna capture an
E3 now the G2 Pawn is hanging so Queen
to G4 but now you can even trade Queen
capture spawn captures Knight captures
on E2 and you are now you you now have a
bishop in the night for Rook uh of
course completely winning and the
problem is if King the F2 does Bishop C5
so you don't have to worry about
anything
uh so after King to F1 uh Wesley did not
play this he played Bishop to D7 but the
position is still incredibly complicated
Queen to A5 biting and now Knights the
D4 but now the problem for Wesley is
that the time has equalized both of them
now have 13 minutes on the clock and 14
more moves uh have to be made for time
control to be reached we have Rook to D1
and now Knight captures an EQ uh
grabbing that uh that that piece and you
don't recapture first Rook to H3 of
course you want to get the queen away
you don't want to allow King captures
here and then Queen captures on E2 now
comes B6 attacking the White Queen and
queen to A6 uh another option is Queen
to D2 which would be much safer for ding
but um they are both a very low on time
here it's just not enough for a
classical game Queen to A6 was played
and now comes Bishop captures and G for
one of the reasons why it was better to
just move the queen back now you're not
in a hurry you can play Bishop captures
and G4 and give up your queen and this
is what it The Rook capture Sun G3
Knight captures on G3 with check and now
King to E1
and uh uh the the the reason why that
quintadito line was better and you're
probably wondering why and okay I will
show it uh instead of queen day6 look at
this queen to D2 now there's Bishop
captures and G4 and after Rook captures
mg3 Knight capture Sun G3 and now what
do you play you're in check if you play
King to F2 just Bishop to D6 and you
don't have captures in G4 because Knight
captures here and you will win back the
queen so this is a a well a a very
strong position for black so that's why
okay Queen A6 was played we already
discussed this bishop captures Rook
captures Knight captures with check and
now King to E1 and the position is now
uh as it is of course the Wesley is
better here uh situation on the clock is
six minutes for ding uh 10 minutes for
Wesley we have Bishop back to E6 now and
queen to B7 of course now uh ding does
not want to allow Wesley's Rook to get
away from the back rank as then of
course the rook and A8 would be hanging
so Rook cap uh chases away the queen
queen to C7 and now Knight to H5 we have
Pawn to G4 biting and now Knight to F6
we have Knight to the E7 check and now
Bishop captures an E7 Queen captures an
E7 and now Rook the E8 chasing away the
queen queen to B7 we have Rook e to B8
again attacking the queen queen to E7
Rook to E8 and queen to B7 uh and after
Rook e to B8 and queen to E7 it was in
this position unmove 40 upon reaching
time control that the players agreed to
a draw as there's seemingly nothing more
to be done here but this is uh well if
you if we are to trust uh very strong
Grand Masters and our good friend the
engine which I've allowed to Crunch the
numbers up until some depth 50. uh this
is uh well either white can save this
with miraculous play or uh black and
just play this indefinitely and win the
game at some point if we I mean you give
this position to any Grand Master he
will just squeeze that squeeze that
squeeze that it doesn't even have to be
someone like Magnus anyone will gladly
play this because white has no moves and
what I mean by this is okay we can uh
check it out a little bit instead of
going for repetition here let's say you
play Pawn to H5 what do you play uh of
course the white cannot allow the the
lines of attack to open up because black
has uh too much material uh for for the
queen black has a rook and Knight and
the bishop that's I mean that's
incredible so you would have to play G5
and the once the Knight comes to H7 okay
it looks like the knight's a bit passive
but the Knight can easily go come back
into the game and now how do you
continue with white there are no active
moves here you can play something like
okay B4 always a good move but doesn't
really go will not take all that far
let's say King F2 you're gonna chase
away the queen let's say queen A6 You're
Gonna Play Knight to f8 now the Knight
is coming into the game let's say King
G3 okay you improve the position a
little bit now Bishop to C8 we have to
kick away the queen from this B7 Square
uh or you could play something like Rook
to see it also also possible and now if
the queen goes back okay now you play G6
uh Rook the C1 over a rook trade and now
again you kick the queen away Queen to
A6 and now Rook the d8 and and uh okay
Rook to C7 if you want to continue
playing this with black you you will
have to give up the A7 Pawn for some
activity let's say Rook to D2 now you'll
play Rook cap percent A7 and after Rook
captures Queen captures The Rook
captures on B2 and now let's assess this
position because this uh there's no
other way to play this out if black
wants to continue this is the only way
for black to continue uh okay let's push
A4 and not a problem we will put a rook
on B3 and now look at this absolutely
everything is defended the bishop
defends The Rook The Rook defends the
pawn the Knight and pawn Defender Bishop
you will put a king on G7 you will bring
your knight let's say to E5 put pressure
on F3 there is no way white can avoid
this there is no uh active plan that
white can come up with white can just
move the queen back and forth and uh you
know hope on every move that he averts
uh a disaster because well uh chair
chances are the disaster will happen
here so it's um I don't know I I still I
I still haven't seen the interview with
Wesley I'm very eager to hear what he
has to say about this maybe uh our
understanding of Chess is just not on
that level maybe maybe Wesley
understands that even with with perfect
play that this is a draw maybe he knows
positions like this but I seriously
doubt it I feel like maybe he just had a
not the greatest of days and then maybe
or he wasn't feeling all that well in
the that he was just happy with uh with
a draw
um uh with the black pieces against the
world classical Champion maybe that's
what it is but it really doesn't feel
like um yeah there's something to
consider here you can play indefinitely
you can continue this for as long as you
want and the only outcome can be either
a draw or or you know chances are pretty
great that you will win this game so
very weird stuff uh I will have more
knowledge to share with you uh in the
next video uh so yeah and that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it
unfortunately for for Yasser it didn't
come true it wasn't
um uh really morphe versus amateur but
now you know what the uh reference
stands for after I really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Lord of
Bones amazing El sarag thank you for
videos Dr Heisenberg and the ding fan
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day